Holly what made you say yes to this
project oh well I i saw the script and
it was it was it was so interesting the
way so sort of nuanced in the terms of
you sort of never quite sure of
characters motivated motivations and
there was a sort of ambiguity about
about about the way that they interact
with each other and that's always really
interesting for a composer because you
know you're not always having to as
opposed to projects where you're having
to hit things on the nose there was much
more sort of scope for finding
interesting sounds and nuances to it how
do you find the mood of a film what do
you do what is your process you watch it
several times ruminate over it i mean
what is your it's tough to explain
obviously i won watches it several times
and and I you know spoke with the
directors I'll quite a lot about you
know what his thoughts about what what
the score needed and so on and then it's
it's just a question of diving in and
and experimenting with you know textures
and colors and sounds and eventually
finding the right blend and mix that
works and that the director is happy
with and the filmmakers happy with
but it's yeah it's it's it's it's tough
to explain but yeah do you remember
where you were how old you were what was
going on your life when you heard the
first movie soundtrack where you said
this is what I want to do oh um I tell
you what i tell you what i can remember
the for the very first piece of film
music that i can remember being
conscious as film music and that was the
the capsule in space scene from what's
that bond movie you only live twice John
Berry that that was a good one I think I
was about seven or eight when I when I
when I first saw that I remember finding
it absolutely terrifying thank you
appreciate thank you